alexandre del vals bonjour vous êtes
aussi l'auteur de la mondialisation
dangereuse à retrouver aux éditions
l'artilleur on peut d'ailleurs voir la
couverture de votre livre à l'écran
bonjour et merci donc d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france d'alors cet
entretien bladimir poutine emmanuel
macron que doit-on retenir finalement et
attire c'est bouger les lignes
je pense pas que ça fasse bouger
énormément les lignes parce que vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir aujourd'hui et
c'est pas dû être pour faire un effet
que je dis cela mais l'europe
malheureusement non seulement kiss-in
gère 10 et quels numéros de téléphone et
on peut dire que l'europe est un
protectorat américain d'un point de vue
stratégique l'europe n'a pas vraiment
son mot à dire
d'ailleurs les américains se sont permis
de dire ces jours ci si on n'est pas
content si ça marche pas s'il n'y a pas
de 6,6 les russes ne cède pas non
seulement il y aura des sanctions mais
vous pourrez dire adieu à nord stream 2
c'est-à-dire le le nouveau le dernier la
dernière branche de gazoducs i qui
renforce le l'approvisionnement de gaz
de l'europe par la russie et c'est assez
extraordinaire de voir des américains
décider avec qui les européens doivent
négocier
jusqu'où doit s'étendre les frontières
de l'otan et de l'union européenne et
avec est acquis les européens devraient
acheter du gaz d'ailleurs les américains
en ce moment ont négocié avec les qatari
pour voir
qu'il ya un scénario où rencontrer une
partie du gaz par du gaz qui passe est
il réaliste d'ailleurs parce que ça se
fait pas comme ça et beaucoup de pays
dépendent grandement du gaz russe ne pas
le remplacer comme cela m'est donc voilà
le monsieur macron a à a essayé de de
procéder à une désescalade
l'entretien s'est plutôt bien passé et
on ne peut que se féliciter de cette de
cet état de fait de cette initiative
française qui rappelle celle de sarkozy
en 2008 pour la géorgie mais
malheureusement il n'est pas certain que
ça soit extrêmement écouter et par
l'otan et par les états unis et
malheureusement aussi par les
partenaires de là france au sein de
l'union européenne comme vous le savez
le président en exercice
le pays qui a six mois de gouvernance
européenne qui préside pendant six mois
n'a pas une marge de manoeuvre énorme il
gère un peu l'agenda mais les décisions
ça reste les membres de l'union
européenne les états et et bien sûr avec
une double lecture entre les led le
conseil et le parlement donc la d6
pardon excusez moi ça veut dire que la
france est totalement alignée sur les
positions américaines qu'il n'y a pas de
petites nuances non justement non là la
france est plutôt un des pays qui est le
plus en faveur d'une bonne relation ou
d'une relation pas mauvaise ou en tout
cas d'un maintien d'un dialogue assez
équilibré avec la russie c'est la
position traditionnelle pas uniquement
du gaullisme et de la france qui ces
deux blessés il est commandé par sa
géographie et son histoire mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas de
nombreux pays européens du nord et de
l'est qui eux surtout pour les pays de
l'est les derniers membres 1 depuis 2004
les pays de l'est excepté à 1 ou 2
notamment la hongrie sont extrêmement
entier russe très atlantiste et ils
reçoivent leurs ordres beaucoup plus des
américains que les instances européennes
et certains de ces pays sont même un
petit peu inconscient un peu comme sa
cage billy en géorgie en 2008 il croit
même qu'on pourrait se permettre même de
de lancer une opération militaire contre
la russie qui n'oseraient pas utiliser
l'armé nucléaire et finalement les
russes ne pourrait pas réagir parce
qu'ils auraient peur des sanctions c'est
peut-être vrai mais c'est quand même
joué avec le feu il faut savoir que
plusieurs pays européens aujourd'hui
encourage en sous-main l'armée
ukrainienne à à reprendre le dombass par
la force ce qui effectivement pourrait
déclencher une réaction militaire et
c'est pour ça que les russes ont placé
des troupes qui l'ont renforcé qu'ils
ont multiplié par deux depuis deux ans
parce que ils craignent une agression de
la part les ukrainiens sur un territoire
dans les rues ce
que les russes ne veulent pas à l'excès
le donbass mais les russes voudrait que
les russophones de l'est est du pays et
un certain nombre de droits c'est
l'origine du problème et malheureusement
les ukrainiens se croit tellement
renforcer et appuyer et soutenu par les
américains et d'autres pays de
l'alliance atlantique qu'ils pensent
pouvoir faire un coup de force comme
saakachvili
et vous avez vu comment a terminé sa
cage billy avec un échec total parce
qu'aucun européen et aucun américain est
allé mourir pour les géorgiens à
l'époque et donc je pense que tout cela
est assez irréaliste et la france a
plutôt un ton assez correct par rapport
aux autres membres de l'alliance
atlantique mais ce que je disais c'est
qu'elle n'est pas elle ne va pas changer
la donne alors le 13 août on en est dans
la phase de dialogue on parle beaucoup
de dialogues de négociations la russie a
donc exposé ces deux mondes washington
et l'otan les ont rejetés en bloc quel
est donc leur stratégie alors la
stratégie de la russie c'est d'avoir
demandé beaucoup plus que ce qu'elle
peut obtenir notamment le retrait de
l'otan de deux membres actuels ce qui
est irréaliste pour obtenir peut-être au
moins la moitié c'est à dire une enfin
que l'otan et l'union européenne fixent
leurs frontières et préviennent que cet
ensemble atlantis puisque l'europe est
aussi un ensemble l'atlantisme l'union
européenne a comme structure de défense
l'otan ont tourné rue c'est un petit peu
pareil c'est tout ça c'est cesser le
monde atlantiste et ce qu'aimeraient la
russie c'est qu' il y ait enfin des
limites car une organisation ou une
entité géopolitique qui s'étend sans
limite ça s'appelle comment même si
c'est démocratique un empire et nous
sommes perçues comme un empire qui va de
plus en plus dans le pré-carré russe
pour un jour avoir une frontière directe
avec les ruses et voir voire pourquoi
pas développer des révolutions de
couleur ou orange ou autres en russie
c'est ce que craignent les russes et
c'est relativement légitime puisque en
1990 james baker helmut kohl d'or bat
chef les pays de l'otan les dirigeants
américains s'étaient entendus
verbalement sur un pacte de non
agression
soit on annule l'otan soit l'otan se
réforment en une organisation politique
ce qu'avait promis baker et
qui ne nuirait pas aux russes est une
organisation qui s'arrêterait un certain
moment qu'il n'irait pas au delà et
malheureusement ça n'a pas été écrit
formellement comme un binding agreement
un accord contraignant et les américains
assez cyniquement ont dit récemment il
ya quelques jours il n'y a jamais eu
aucun accords écrits contraignant qui
s'engage qui engage les américains à
arrêter le processus dexant d'extension
de l'otan vers la russie c'est très
malhonnête de la part les américains
parce qu'il ya eu en tout cas un
gentleman agreement il y a eu une
négociation entre chefs d'état de
l'époque qui était beaucoup plus raison
qu'aujourd'hui écoutez vos petits dans
ta et gorbatchev le raid qui quand même
un modérés bien vus en occident
gorbatchev lui-même le déplore souvent
il n'est pas un adorateur de poutine
mais gorbatchev dit c'est vrai qu'on
nous avait donné des garanties certes
non contraignant mais donc mais les
occidentaux les occidentaux nous avait
promis de ne jamais aller vers l'est au
delà de la pologne et des pays baltes il
ya donc n'arrête coupat et de mlle des
affaires russes et des affaires
biélorussie et les un féru crânienne et
géorgienne depuis ces années qu'il est
donc eu des promesses manifestement qui
ne sont pas tenues alexandre delval vous
êtes et géopolitologue merci et d'avoir
été avec nous mais aussi auteur de la
mondialisation dangereuse aux éditions
l'artilleur merci à vous